chapter 7 the sorting algorithm
the world henceforth will be run by
synthesizers
people able to put together the right
information
at the right time think critically about
it
and make important choices wisely
e.o wilson
the day science begins to study
non-physical phenomenon
it will make more progress in one decade
than
all the previous centuries of its
existence
nikola tesla don't
throw the baby out with the bathwater
separate the wheat from the chaff the
two
fields that have most profoundly
advanced civilization
over the last millennia are science and
spirituality
their good codes need to be amplified
and their bad codes need to be archived
followed by a synthesis of the two into
one examples of good codes that need to
be kept are the scientific
method and mercha eleades hierophany
which are manifestations of the sacred
examples of bad codes that need to be
archived include perverse incentives
dogmas and fundamentalism
science must help spirituality validate
higher levels of consciousness and
spirituality
must help keep science morally and
ethically on track
to prevent catastrophic malevolences
like what happened with the
proliferation of thousands of nuclear
weapons the last 75
years other babies
to synthesize and drain the bath water
indigeneity and modernity eastern and
western wisdoms
usa conservatives and liberals
usa and china silicon valley and
hollywood
synthesize the indigenous seventh
generation principle
with applied science to create a more
harmonic
and balanced engine pulling humanity
forward
synthesize the usa conservative focus on
the individual stepping up
with the usa liberal focus to augment
the social
fabric to enable gift actualization